انضم الينا من بني نعيم شرقيه الخليل
مراسل الجزيره منتصر نصار منتصر ما الوضع
لديك نعم اياده بالفعل نحن نقف امام
المنزل الذي اقتحمته قوات الاحتلال هذه
الليله واخترته
بالهدم دمار كبير في هذا المنزل كما يظهر
في هذه الصوره واللافت الانتباه ايضا حيث
جرت العاده في مثلها كذا امور عندما يقتحم
الاحتلال منازل منفذي عمليات وياخذ قياسات
المنزل العائله بكل الاحوال تقوم بتفريغ
المنزل من كافه محتوياته وهذا ما يظهر في
هذا المنزل على الاقل قوات الاحتلال
اقتحمت بلده بني نعيم فجر هذا اليوم
واستمرت ل ساعات الصباح الاولى قامت باخذ
القياسات في المنزل كما يظهر في هذه
الصوره ووضع علامات واشارات على جدران
المنزل
وابلغت العائله بان انها ستعود هذه الليله
الليله القادمه لهدم المنزل طبعا المنزل
الذي نتواجد فيه مكون من طابقين اختر
بالكامل اضافه الى منزل اخر حيث ان
العمليه التي وقعت في رعانا شمال تل ابيب
قوات الاحتلال تتهم الشاب احمد احمد زيدات
24 عامو عمه محمود 44 عام تتهمهم
ب وقوف را تنفيذ هذه العمليه وبالتالي هي
اخطرت هذا المنزل المكون من طابقين منزل
اخر بمعنى ان الهدم والتفجير سيكون لثلاثه
منازل طبعا قوات الاحتلال داهمت البلده
واعتدت على اهالي منفذي العمليه واعتدت
على جيرانهم حيث اصيب شابان ايضا بجراح تم
نقلهما بواسطه الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
اضافه ايضا الى قيامها باغلاق المنطقه
بشكل كامل حتى ساعات الصباح الاولى كما
ايضا نشير الى ان والد احد منفذي هذه
العمليه لازال معتقلا لدى قوات الاحتلال
كانت قوات الاحتلال اعتقلت الوالد
والاشقاء افرجت عن الاشقاء وابقت على
والده معتقلا يظهر في هذه الصوره ايضا هذه
الثقوب التي تضعها قوات الاحتلال في
الجدران وهذا كله تمهيدا كما ذكرنا ل
عمليه الهدم التي من المتوقع ان تتم خلال
الايام القليله القادمه مع الاشاره ايضا
الى ان هنالك ايضا ثلاثه منازل الاخرى في
الخليل مختره بالهدم وهي ل الشهيد عبد
القادر القواسمي والشهيد نصر الله
القواسمي والشهيد حسن قفيش ايضا قوات
الاحتلال اخطرت وهم الشهداء الثلاثه الذين
تتهمهم قوات الاحتلال بتنفيذ عمليه وقعت
عند حاجز النفق في بيت لحم كانت اخطرت هذه
المنازل بالهدم ايضا واعطت العائله مهله
قانونيه للاعتراض ورفضت قوات الاحتلال هذا
الالتماس المقدم وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن
ثلاثه منازل في منط منطقه دائره السير في
مدينه الخليل مختره بال الهدم والتفجير
اضافه الى منزلين في بلده بني نعيم وهذا
المنزل الذي نتواجد فيه طبعا قوات
الاحتلال مؤخرا وقبل وقوع العمليه قوات
الاحتلال تقتحم بين نعيم اكثر من مره
وهنالك
مستوطن متواجد بشكل دائم عند مدخل هذه
البلده يحرد بشكل مستمر وبشكل متواصل على
اهالي بلده بني نعيم شرق الخليل وبالتالي
الاقتحامات مستمره ومتواصله وتداهم قوات
الاحتلال هذه البلده تفتش البيوت والمنازل
صادرت عدد من المركبات خلال الفتره
القليله الماضيه وهذا ياتي في اطار وفي
سياق ما يجري في الخليل جنوب الضفه
الغربيه بشكل عام حيث الاغلاق المستمر
لمداخل وايضا استمرار قوات الاحتلال بعزل
المناطق في الخليل الجنوب عن الوسط وعن
الشرق والغرب ايضا وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن
محافظه الخليل التي تعتبر من من اكثر
المحافظات المتضرره من مووضوع سياسات
الاغلاقات المستمره والمتواصل نهيك ايضا
مياده عن ان اكبر عدد معتقلين منذ السابع
من اكتوبر كان من مدينه الخليل هذا ما
تحدث به نادي الاسير بالامس في بيان مفصل
قال ان 1300 معتقل من الخليل لوحدها منذ
السابع من اكتوبر نتحدث عن 31 حاله اعتقال
لسيدات في الخليل ايضا ونتحدث كذلك ايضا
عن كما ذكرنا مواصله واستمراريه موو سياسه
الا هذا المنزل كما تشاهدون مفرغ تماما من
محتوياته والعائله تنتظر في اي لحظه ان
يقتحم الاحتلال هذا المنزل وان يقوم
بعمليه التفجير لهذا المنزل المكون من
طابقين وللمنزل اخر ايضا في البلده على
مقربه من هذا المكان من بني نعيم شرقيه
الخليل مراسل الجزيره منتصر نصار شكرا
جزيلا لك